foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I want to apologize to you guys for
being a little bit late I had some stuff
that was going on and I didn't get home
in time and I want to apologize but
we'll be getting started here in a
couple minutes
foreign
[Music]
all right what's going on guys you guys
should be able to hear me uh hopefully
you'll be able to hear King fun uh it's
just it's just been a crazy day guys and
I apologize uh you know I know uh thanks
a bit could you hear me King yes of
course
okay why can't I hear King hold up
all right King talk
now I'm talking
hello
oh my God it was working just fine six
seconds ago
all right just keep talking talking here
you King
is it my headset
talking talking to words
talking talking
death of audio
I know you can hear you guys hear King
okay you guys can hear King it's just
all right try to talk now
they always be making this so
complicated
all right hold up
usually I just switching it and it comes
right on
the Gunnies have blocked the ability to
hear me
it's so sad messed up to be honest with
you
oh okay okay never mind
all right now
you can hear me
can you hear the words coming from my
mouth
I don't know why
adulterated
oh God
as I look upon your frail human form I'm
about to have a
as I contemplate
what we shall do with you
your time is limited mortal
as we plan to Feast hold up King it
worked last week just fine
audio
Xbox headset
poetry all kinds of nonsense right now
dog poetry you want okay let me see let
me get my back see I I see you there
it's on Xbox Twitter these Tweedledum
how can we crush the Mortal shell
let me count the ways keep speaking the
word yeah I don't want to hear it
while Eric tries to figure out
what his frail mortal fingers
how he can hear a God
I will talk to you about oh there he
goes there we go there we go I can hear
you oh Jesus Christ man
I did it three times and it wasn't
working
um
we don't need your nonsense all right so
apologize for for all that guys let me
Focus the little camera I do have
yes a CP
it's just it's stressful man when like
stuff's supposed to go the way it's
supposed to but everywhere
they're like no we're not going to uh
we're not going to work
all right
so what's going on you guys r r with the
Lord It's Me and King we're going to be
breaking down stuff we're gonna be
talking about stuff there's a lot of
stuff going on uh with you know some
movies that we've chosen for each other
there's also uh some DC stuff going on
you know we got a lot of stuff in store
for you guys and I think it's uh going
to be an interesting conversation man uh
so all right all right let's let's what
do you want to tackle first I feel like
we got to save the last of us and the DC
stuff for last because that that's that
that that's the the high like this the
the cherry on top so I think we're gonna
start I did watch the violent line I I
was able to pull it off at the last
minute
and we could talk about it if you want
this is
yeah so
I I played uh not not played I watched
the violent night and for those of you
that don't know the violent nights like
a kind of a spin on Santa Claus that I
don't think I've ever seen before I
don't think anyone's ever tried
something like this before I've seen
Santa Claus like kind of kill people
there's a lot of aspects that Santa has
graced the presence when it comes to
stuff but it's it's never been this and
it's it's interesting man it's
interesting you know what
oh King is off
oh my God
all right hello everyone okay can can
you hear it now can you hear me now put
a one in the chat
a one
if you can hear the king they should be
able to hear you so you know if you kind
of hit me
unmute King
he's not muted talking
I am talking oh one they can hear you
they can hear you okay good so I I did
watch it you know unfortunately I
watched it to like the last minute
because I had a lot of stuff going on
this week this is like a really bad week
like a really bad week stuff going on
almost every day I have been watching uh
you know my girlfriend's daughter a
little bit more this week because she's
been uh working picking up hours so it
this game this movie isn't something you
can really watch with the little kids no
you can't watch this movie with a kid
but hold on let me get uh Killian Brown
what up Killian brown with the two
dollar Super Chat thank you very much we
do appreciate that sup Lords and did
King get a chance to see Levi Flex yet
yes I did get a chance to see Levi Flex
um
Levi right now and I haven't seen him in
a vulnerable state yet but Levi right
now seems like one of those uh
overconfident cocky characters is that
you have to break his confidence at some
point in time in the show so I can't
wait for that moment because I'm an
Aaron fan and
um an Armin fan
I don't like that dude I don't like the
fact that he had to stomp him in his
face and his tooth had to come out and
grow right back so yeah I can't wait to
see Levi get broken pause
if you know what's funny when it comes
to uh to that
um you you're not gonna see that like
look I will say there's a point where
Levi does get humbled
but it's not because of his ego it's not
because
of the way he pers Roy he does stuff he
gets humbled because
he uh as I would say underestimated
someone oh don't don't tell me don't
tell me I'll get to it you know we got a
lot what okay I guess we'll start with
the uh attack or tie what what what have
you caught what is the last episode you
watching this has been uh incredibly
Bonkers week uh I've been watching
Ragnarok of the Gods
oh I actually I need to watch the first
season I remember I watched like two
episodes and I never went back to it all
right so anyway attic is a fraud I love
this stuff I love um manoi mono combat
and this stuff gets me so pumped up I'm
I can't even lie so um like I I watched
the first season and I was amped and
they left it on the Cliffhanger because
you had Hercules versus uh Jack the
Ripper and uh when we got a chance to
Jack the Ripper
um
it's
it was more than I expected
I really I really thought that it the
the yo they can take a mundane character
that you know nothing about and give
them such a rich intense uh fake law and
then craft a story around it I love
Japanese animation I love
the ability to take something and bend
it and twist it to fit their narrative
at that point in time uh and the way
they they did Hercules they gave
Hercules a different type of law
and they Bend and they Twisted it but
it's always about overcoming and and
persevering and these battles is so
intense uh so you know my wife was
watching the battles with me and she's
like
I can't take it anymore like like the
the way they leave you on Cliffhanger so
yeah man I highly recommend Ragnarok of
the Gods is on Netflix season two is up
I binged watched it I didn't get a
chance to watch any Attack on Titan and
I thought I was going to get a chance to
watch some Attack on Titan but that
thing kind of consumed me as soon as I
saw it it's like Baki or the kinsing
tournament when those things pop up I go
straight to them and I binge watch the
hell out of them that in seven deadly
sins I'm a huge fan of that stuff so
seven deadly sins is good
I've been meaning to go back to that
like I have like it's it's something
that's on the backlog uh that now that
you speak so highly of it might go on
there quicker but I have a meaning to go
back on that so all right all right
let's let's get back you know I'm gonna
restart the segment you know we're gonna
go back we will talk about violent DC
stuff but let's let addict talk about it
yeah so Violet Knight you know King hit
me up last week so I want you to watch
violent night
unfortunately I waited to the very last
minute because I was going to watch a
movie uh with King it's uh the uh the
you people movie that's on Netflix
unfortunately I wasn't able to watch
that I did and I got a whole bunch to
talk about I did watch violent night now
why did you make me watch this movie
okay
I'm I'm
one of those people that I don't
celebrate Christmas but I love Christmas
Time movies
and Christmas Time movies you know you
see people all in the spirit and stuff
like that and I think that stuff is
really fun and cool but this was a
Different Twist on it this was like a
die-hard Twist on it it was like you
know because everybody likes to say
there's a big uh controversy it's Die
Hard a Christmas movie is it not and
it's a Christmas movie you know Die Hard
is a Christmas movie to me it is I I
guess me and you different a little
there I would consider Die Hard a movie
like an action movie took a place around
Christmas right Christmas but there's a
lot of people that watch that on
Christmas right a lot of us older heads
so
this movie
was in the vein of that you know um
Santa Claus wanting to win his love back
in Mrs Claus uh he's drinking Santa
Clauses he's a lush but not really Santa
Claus really believes the list is real
all that stuff is real and the parents
are trying to tell you know the kids
that you know Santa Claus isn't real and
when Okay so
the whole premise of the movie is it's a
interracial couple that have a daughter
and they're on the outs and they're uh
getting a divorce so they they've gotten
the divorce but they're separated and
they're spending the night at the his
mother's house
uh and she's immensely rich and
everybody's sucking up to the moms you
know because they want to be next in
line for her money and
um you know he's like really over it he
just wants his family and he's trying to
get back in good graces uh with his his
wife his ex-wife and they have their kid
there and she's the only kid of mixed
color there right so
and not like that really matters I don't
even know why they did it but they did
it anyway so
um she sends letters to Santa Claus and
you know they told us Santa Claus wasn't
real but Santa Claus is trying to make
his Run for the night and he gets stuck
in his house
and this house is that house
and lo and behold a hit squad is there
to and it's a hit squad like it's the
money and they infiltrated the place by
opposing as the help
and it's just it's a wild Wicked turn of
events and there's so much joy to see
but as he's going along he's doing Sandy
claw stuff and he's telling these people
um yeah when you when you went back when
you when I brought you the bike when I
got you the bike for Christmas and you
know you ran over your cousin's finger
or something like that and he's like
that's that made you a bad boy and he
started saying the the the hit squad's
names because it was going by names like
Peppermint Patty and and candy cane and
um uh the Pillsbury Doughboy stuff like
that you know Holly uh Christmas stuff
and he just started calling him out by
their real names so these dudes is like
how this dude knows our name
it was so much fun because then they go
into the law of how he became Santa
and I just I thought the movie was
really good in its execution and it
stayed true to what it was
it was a movie about Santa Claus
trying maybe giving up on the love
and hate him and Mrs Claus ain't as
tight as they supposed to be but he sees
this family fighting for their stuff and
this little girl who is like home alone
too was like it was a slash Home Alone
movie I just yeah I actually I did like
when they were in the uh when they had
in the attic and there was a lot of Like
Home Alone Vibes going that was cool
yeah it's just like I'm not saying that
it was a bad take on something it's just
okay here's my biggest thing okay all
right talk to me
I was for this when I thought that he
was gonna have some form of like that's
what I'm looking for like magical powers
to fight like the this this Army because
that's what it was it was an Army he was
yeah and to me
he's a magical being
I thought they were gonna take more of
that aspect because at that point when
like you know
what what happens happens like the barn
area yeah it's like you mean to tell me
this dude didn't get hit really like it
just it didn't feel realistic to me you
know what I'm saying yeah but he was
Santa when he got that sledgehammer and
he was like Thor
it
it was a Hope movie and it gave a lot of
hope you know that little girl had a lot
of Hope
um and then you found out a lot of
things about how uh the hit squad got
tipped off because I really I really
encourage everyone to see the movie be
honest with you this is a guilty
pleasure this is a night definitely a
guilty pleasure you know you go get a
little drink a little sit down it's a
guilty pleasure this is something that I
guarantee you you would tell somebody
about it after you see it be it good or
be it bad but it's definitely going to
get out some laughs in you and it's
going to give you that Christmas feel so
if you didn't get a good Christmas movie
this year I think violent night
definitely fit that bill and if you're a
person that likes you know a little
blood splatter hair in it because I'm
gonna tell you right now
they don't mince words it's definitely
heavy on a cursing and it's definitely
heavy on the violence and the gore the
gore is kind of insane I think that's my
only thing it was like I feel like
the first part okay you know where he
he's he I would have liked it to have
been a Redemption you know he was losing
faith with himself he's starting to lose
his own powers you know what I'm saying
Redemption when when the reindeer
showed up I I feel you but it just it
just to me
it should have been more him do you get
what I'm saying like I'm feeling like
the beginning when they show up at the
beginning they do their thing and he's
happened to like pretty much fight them
as a man because his own mind has put
him on that level because he's not
really because you even see he's having
a hard time using his powers at the
beginning oh yeah and to me people stop
believing I I wanted it to be one of
those things where the longer the movie
goes by the more he gets back into his
Vibe and then you start seeing instead
of walking around with objects and
that's all I'm going to say right he's
walking around using his own stuff you
know
like like you know when when they they
did the Magic Bag I thought they were
going to utilize that more yo that magic
back is crazy here let me go to the
spoiler room real quick like I thought
what was gonna happen is they were going
to use
the the magic bag like she was gonna end
up wishing for stuff for him to use to
fight you don't want to be crazy but
it's just like to me it's just like
that's so part two though
is that how no I mean that's four part
two I mean I thought the movie was good
enough that it deserves a part two
but let me get this uh Super Chat the
black Harry Potter five dollar Super
Chat uh record of Ragnarok is fire
Hogwarts Legacy in eight days people
definitely if that's something that you
definitely looking forward to hell yeah
but you know record of Ragnarok is
definitely crazy
I probably said Ragnarok of the Gods
yeah yeah
that's my only thing my only thing is
why didn't you use more of your powers
like if it would have been one of those
things I think his powers were
diminished well that's what I'm saying
like the first set of people he had to
fight them man-to-man you know what I'm
saying but then when it came to like the
people in the ball when the when the
reinforcements showed up and I'm not
that's all I'm gonna read that up when
the reinforcements showed up and it
seemed like it was over for him I'm
thinking he about to use some like magic
to get out of this no it just ironically
everyone got bad aim no no one no one
aims to shoot they shoot to aim oh bad
guys can't shoot they're Stormtroopers
I would have preferred if that
particular moment like he has like
like some kind of up uppity thing where
he starts believing in himself and then
you see that juice starting to fly it
could even have been that gory I I don't
mind the glory I don't mind using Santa
Claus but I'm like the difference
between having what's the difference
between having any other person in there
doing that you could have took spot you
could have took Santa Claus out of the
equation and not much would have changed
yeah but to me Santa Claus was was the
Golden Goose in this matter and to me
you didn't use utilize the Santa Claus
portion of the movie but that's what it
is about nobody believed anymore and he
got his powers back because one girl
truly believed
and as more people started believing his
power started coming back
because remember when he started saying
those guys names they started believing
and I feel you on that I I
I just personally feel like when the
second set of people showed up when he
was in that Barn he would have been lit
is if he like start like he started just
like what's up you wouldn't have got his
backstory then you want to tell you how
he became Santa Claus and why he was
able to do the stuff that he was able to
do because oh boy it was wicked with his
hands boy Santa Claus get busy
I I just think it would have been cool
is if he really utilized that in that
Barn like there was some kind of
flashback maybe maybe something happened
where he like thought of something that
his wife said or something and he got
those juices back they could have cut
the gourd they could have kept
everything and like imagine him if they
wouldn't have burned the biggest thing
they had which was the the little uh
Santa thing the the magical back there
and he's just reaching like for
nunchucks and stuff in this bag you know
what I'm saying like they had to take
away his advantage to make him gritty
with it I'm sorry I I like what they did
they they put him at a disadvantage and
to show you that Santa's gonna overcome
all he needs just one person to believe
in him I fell for the movie Hook Line
and Sinker uh my rating of popcorn for
the movie is a three popcorn definitely
something to pique your interest get in
there and check it out that's I get
three popcorn for him man so you get
three yeah I Gotta Give it two all right
I feel you guys I'm not saying you know
that it wasn't a bad movie
I just personally feel like
the things that I would have watched for
cool concept you know you get Santa
Claus Santa Claus is in there
but what I would have enjoyed is
for them to utilize that Santa Claus
thing you know what I'm saying for for
them to have used the magical abilities
or something like that because to me
when I heard what when I actually
because I thought this was about Santa
Claus going loco that's what I thought
but then when I kind of like understood
what was about to happen that's what I
thought was gonna happen throughout the
whole movie is like he was gonna start
like you know being really fast or
something or or like because a lot of
like religiously he did use his magic to
fly away on some stuff yeah
don't don't Santa Claus's credit man
oh okay
do stuff for something man I don't I
want to spoil it so bad but I don't
because this is such a dope film but
let's get on to this old film
you have me watch it came out in 2001
old film what was that old film Frailty
Frailty
oh
God
so so so go ahead explain to the viewers
what Frailty is you know
Frailty is a psychological uh child
abuse Thriller
that's actually a very uh
very good description of it it is it is
it is probably
once I saw Matthew McConaughey had a fat
face I was like oh this is after he did
that cowboy joint where he had AIDS
oh I mean this is before then because
after that he has never looked the same
after he had to lose all that weight for
that movie
um
this film oh God where do I start do I
start in the beginning where you know
the father you know because all right
there's a
a father and two okay so so this is such
an old movie we're gonna stay in spoiler
territory like the whole time yeah we
got to see a spoiled territory because
if you didn't see this film
don't worry about it um
it's it's
oh my God it was like pulling teeth to
be honest with you to watch this film
because I don't think it's that bad I
think it's terrible in a sense that
this kid he had these children's crushed
questioning their reality and if anybody
knows anything about children especially
little boys they
if if your father's in your life you
look up to your dad and sometimes if
he's not and he comes around you look up
to your dad if he's a good person he's
trying
and you know this guy was tasked with
taking care of his two kids after his
wife died giving birth to his last child
um which was Adam
and Adam Adam was um
he's very impressionable to his pops and
his pops never took out the fact that
the the wife died
uh given childbirth on this kid
highly religious he gets highly
religious as a very religious film and
then one night he runs inside the room
and he tells him oh you know uh God gave
me a vision
and his demons loose in this world and
it's our job to take him out of here
but to the untrained eye they're going
to look like normal people
but when he places his hand on him he
get to see all the horrific crimes and
stuff that they've done and and God is
going to give them three weapons and
these three weapons is the only weapons
to kill these demons
and um
and normal weapons Bros
Otis is a pipe
hell is going on here man
I'm not I'm not saying that Frailty
isn't really good in that time in 2001
for the time it was good
2023.
[Music]
it just don't hold up the same it has
deer legs it's like wobbly it's it
doesn't give me the same that I think it
would have been back then
and I do love Matthew McConaughey but
see
learning everything it's like usual
suspects this movie felt really usual
suspect-ish right if anybody saw users
suspects and uh find out who Kaiser Sosa
is at the end of the film
and he starts walking I'm glad that
you've seen that because that was going
to be a movie I had I was gonna oh don't
you ever no more your old films
digging in the crates for your own films
that's done I'm gonna hold my old films
from when you have me watch some stupid
stuff so yeah no doubt but okay so
throughout the film they have you trying
to and they they the film is questioning
your reality having you question the
reality of what's really going on is
this guy a serial killer is he's taking
his children and indoctrinating them
into murder because it's a part where
the little boy they have to get with
this one dude and the little boy acts
like he lost something under your car
and the guy goes over and bends over uh
they got the dude tied up and and
they're going to do things to this man
um
he indoctrinated these children into
whatever scheme that he had going but in
the end
it truly turns out that he turned the
little one into a serial killer because
the oldest son wasn't about none of that
the oldest son
definitely was fighting back and he
locked his oldest son into a Cellar for
seven days and he said we'll let you out
if you see God I don't know if the kids
started seeing hallucination because he
wasn't eating I don't know if he was
having you know the sensory uh
deprivation when you're alone for a long
period of time they do that in isolation
in jail people start seeing visions they
start hearing voices and stuff like that
so I don't know if the little kid was
suffering from stuff like that but all I
can do with watching this film was like
this is a horrible horrible man and he's
doing these stuff to his kids and he got
his kids involved into this mess so I I
truly watched it through gritted teeth
and I just was like whatever I'm gonna
get to the end of the film and then
there's a plot twist
which is hilarious because they have you
thinking it's one way and all along it's
this way
um
I'm really gonna tell you this is the
first movie I can tell you that it's
probably a two popcorn for me oh it's a
super popcorn yeah yeah he thinks it's a
two popcorn yeah y'all just giving it
more than two popcorn because of Matthew
McConaughey that's it but he wasn't
really in the film he was in the phone
talking about it
when the murders and stuff was going
down it was the little kids in the pops
nah I'm cool I'm cool on this film God
bless it's dope for two popcorn two
popcorn for the king I'm giving it three
I bet I don't I don't I don't think it's
like amazing amazing but I think it's a
good a good movie Killian Brown Tupac
one
Usual Suspects
is absolute fire
definitely the truth I mean that's
that's how you tell a film
and that's how you have a huge plot
twist at the end
but it was dope
they tried
[Laughter]
uh
ah
I thought she was gonna like it I ain't
gonna lie man I I really thought she was
gonna like it I would have loved it if
they wasn't doing the indoctrination of
the children do you do you think that
you being a father interrupts you from
really enjoying it because like you
you're thinking of your your your kids
and you know how bad that is as a father
and treat that oh but you know what he
was truly unhinged I thought the man was
unhinged so
as a father you know you're too close to
something you see something a certain
way and you always want to protect your
babies so man I'll be honest with you
the dude was unhinged to even have his
children participate in that I've seen
other movies where people you know their
father was on a crusade from God didn't
involve the kids but yeah he did and
what's funny is you know there's a part
in the movie what that is crazy where
he's like the Angels told me you're a
demon I don't believe that yeah and he
was like on my faith and loving you
overpowered that part but if it's
divinely said then you're contradicting
yourself right there that's why the kid
never believed anything he said
they got to a point where the kid was
like oh my dad's bonkers
I gotta stop this dude like when he hit
him with this the accident
did you be honest did you expect that
that hole in the chest that he delivered
there like um I expected that kid to
stop him
because okay so once you once you lock
your kid in the basement come on man
what what come on man nah hell no I
wasn't about none of that that that's
respect to the little brother to stop
him
sucks sucky movie
I mean I get it man I get it
all right me on a couple of things today
but
um all right so you didn't get a chance
to see you people okay hold up hold up
so uh the next subject we're gonna be
doing uh we're gonna be talking about
you people it's a huge movie right now
going on on Twitter it's a you know a
lot of social aspects going on in it
um I I got a little bit of a um yeah
Netflix I got a little bit of a
play-by-play it wasn't a whole lot yeah
I I do want to go and actually watch the
movie because I've been told it's
actually a good movie and IT addresses
social aspects we have in society today
uh so you know to tell the people about
the movie man tell the people what I did
like that I didn't get a watch and I was
a little upset
is I didn't uh I really liked
um what's his name Jonah Hill seemed
like he's the first movie I've ever seen
him in where he was more of a serious
role than other movies I've seen him man
well I love Jonah Hill's acting chops
and um my wife let me know that was
nipsy hustle's uh wife that was playing
uh Amira uh his love interest in the
film and his his name is Ezra in the
film this is the first time that uh you
know Eddie Murphy's he's been back but
he's the last film he did was Dolomite I
believe so just out of curiosity was you
know how they like to throw in these big
names but they don't really use them a
lot they don't get a lot of screen time
was he in this movie a lot Eddie Murphy
was all over this movie in in a fashion
that a lot of people aren't gonna
probably be comfortable with and I don't
think this film is made for you to be
comfortable all right so this film is
attacking your uncomfortability when it
comes to uh stuff that we try to close
our eyes to but let me take a step back
real quick and explain
there's uh what I did like about the
film is the coming together of families
and the union of families what we don't
do and what we've grown away from as a
society I guess in my immediate
circumference is the meeting of the
families before you get married uh the
asking for the the daughter's hand in
marriage the respect that uh uh uh
Prospect uh son-in-law is supposed to
have for the family and the meeting of
the minds that is supposed to happen
between two families I don't see that a
lot happening and I'm glad that this
happened in this film this film is
really crafted around uh two individuals
that find love with each other even
though one is Jewish and one is uh
Muslim black and and they
find a a bond and they try to cultivate
that Bond but we see that the Family
Ties starts to yank that apart because
there's so much un talked about uh
things that people want to have
conversations with but they don't know
how to have these conversations and you
see the awkwardness within both families
trying to get to know uh the other child
like uh Ezra's family trying to get to
know Mira
and uh uh I mean uh yeah Ezra's family
trying to get to know a mirror and uh
Amira's family trying to get to know
Ezra
Eddie Murphy
took the stance of a strong militant
black man
he comes across angry comes across
belligerent he comes across
disrespectful dismissive
um
just out of curiosity is it out of spite
because he doesn't like the scenarios
that he's in or is it out of his
experience that he doesn't like what's
going on everything okay
he comes across
he comes across very very belligerent
very he feels if he uh puts up this this
from because he wants to protect his
daughter regardless of what both of them
right the the mother wants or Ezra's
mother wants and father wants what's the
best for Ezra and amir's mother and
father wants what's best for her right
but they both feel both families feel in
the heart of hearts that's not gonna
happen like that because you know the
race isn't supposed to stick together we
don't come from that right we grew up a
little bit different we grew up now I'm
in a Melting Pot things are different
but they're older so
you see these uncomfortable
conversations that they get to have when
they meet them
and it's it's very uncomfortable you
know it's crazy though just starting to
interrupt you King like you look look at
Jonah Hill in this picture that I have
on the screen he he is grown like like
you don't see him looking like this
serious ever like I remember him very
safe I remember him back in like
accepted you know what I'm saying like
I'm pretty sure that was hidden accepted
but it's just like uh he's been in so
many he's more of a comedy movie and I
think they do it this is comedy yeah
they they that's what I say I think that
they try to like intertwine the serious
Tome of Comedy to try to like it seems
like to me it's like one of those things
where it's like this is a lot of
uncomfortable conversations
uncomfortable scenarios but we're gonna
make you laugh between those ladies yeah
and they do it they do it well but they
also do it as in teaching
and and you get you get a chance to see
families Reaching Across trying in some
form of fashion
but then there's a message and and the
message is
get to know the individuals right get to
know the people don't don't
use them as objects or don't view them
as what the past did because it was a
lot of past being brought up like
slavery
um the holiday and it's hurt on both
sides
and if they actually took the time out
to listen to one another they would have
heard the hurt inside each other's
voices but they were so busy trying to
protect both sides like uh the both
children
and they're grown but I did like that
like when my wife pointed out
um
they the families did come together
though to go to the wedding uh what you
call it like the pre-wedding party
they did get a chance to sit down they
did do those things and that was
something good to see because everybody
wants to know that they have the back
end of the family be they right or be
they wrong
to have those people fortified in in
accepting your choices and trying to see
your side of it so I thought the film
did a good uh representation on trying
to bridge a gap especially there's a
large gap between the Jewish community
and the black community oh and really
Muslims um but you know black community
and I think this will start to show a
little bit more I think this movie would
do a lot a lot more good than it would
do harm for bringing the light a lot of
the stuff that they were talking about
it was good to see it was really good to
see I'm not going to give you any
spoilers because this thing is new on
Netflix and it just came out so I would
encourage anybody that is uh curious
about the movie like comedy or or in a
interracial relationship and it's having
these struggles with their family
members you know to sit down and see how
they deal with it in this film to see if
you can use those same Tools in your
life to try to bring those tools out to
fix any little things that's going on
because it's very important I'm dealing
with an interracial relationship now
basically and it's um Dominican and
black so it's it's a language barrier
just a cultural barrier and it's it's
just learning to bridge that Gap in
between and I just found it very
refreshing that they didn't run from any
of the hard questions what I find like
interesting is like if you really sit
back and you think about it like
the way the world was originally
orchestrated with everyone having
different languages like we were really
never supposed to intertwine like we are
like but throughout years we've learned
how to break those barriers figure out
each other's languages and and we're
here where we are now and it's just you
know we got a long way to go I I do even
though that we've talked to I think I am
going to go back and watch this because
I saw I saw I watched like five minutes
of it right before I went to uh this
morning uh and when I talked to you he's
like watch violent night I should have
watched this I I sure was this see the
thing was
this you know you watch this with your
girl you know watch this because this is
a good film there's no problems you know
there's a lot of curse and mostly from
Eddie
what you gonna be like wow really but he
plays his role so well
um and it's so good seeing successful
families right
I mean that's that's what you want to
see successful families this reminds me
of a movie I've seen about like the
interracial thing like being that shock
Factor because that's what it seemed
like this movie's about what was it it
had I think Ashton Kutcher in it or
something and he was dating a a black
woman and when she brought him back home
the family was not feeling it like I I I
can't remember what movie that was but
it's I like the concept of it I just
need to actually sit down and watch it
um you know I'm showing the the actors
on here now the the chick to the far
right that's the chick that used to
talking about yeah you talk about yes
yeah yeah check this out right my wife
thought that uh Nia Long was in
Destiny's Child and she was like I'm
telling you that's the girl from
destination
no boo-boo
she's not but yeah I'm glad you're
watching and I definitely exposed you
funeral is another one I like funeral
that's the one with uh that's the one
with I don't know if Chris Rock's in it
they gave the white kid uh I think some
some pills and he was sitting on the
roof he gave him some ecstasy or
something like that that was on Netflix
not long ago that was on Netflix not
long ago I it's it's it there's a lot of
good movies out there you guys like you
know what's funny is
my my dad was raised as a racist and you
know uh rest in peace but you know we we
got into an argument once because we was
watching Barbershop and
I was telling them I'm like because me
and him always went back and forth like
my dad was like one of those radical
people you know he right I won't go into
some of his comments but you know he he
would always argue with me about like
schematic stuff like that and and I was
like let's it's just like this we're
watching The Barbershop I was like Dad
this would not be the same with white
people like it just wouldn't like
there's a such thing as black humor and
that's what this movie does well because
that's why it's so successful he's like
no they could have easily put white
people in here I'm like name some actors
that could have did just as well
crickets he couldn't understand what
he's saying if they would have did
Barbershop for white people but see but
I I feel like the two like the two
environments are so different it would
be a different movie yeah so that's what
I'm saying right because the black
barbershop and there's a barbershop
scene in this film funny that you said
that the barbershop the black barbershop
is where people go to snap uh you know
it's everything happens in a black
barbershop everything when I go to my
barber shop I mean this well there's a
hairdresser in the back but these guys
are selling TVs in the back I see tcl's
leaving all the time
um my barber is a notary so people come
in and he's like hold on one second and
he's actually notarizing stuff that's
just going and we're talking about the
football game we're talking about the
baseball game they got lines on the wall
talking about uh like uh who's gonna get
what on they're you know betting on the
game it's so much going on in a black
barber shop and that's all you hear I've
never heard of anything going on in a
white ball there's nothing it's they
talking about sports so that's about it
like yeah yeah so and what's funny is is
like I it's it's awfully ironic like all
there is a a rush there there is a
barber shop in Virginia that has a white
owner but the majority of the barber
shops here they're all black owned like
almost all of them well I I I was
talking to Cog once because he's like yo
he's like you're going to eat threes
he's gonna need to you're gonna need to
to upkeep that face yo you can't go out
there looking like that and I was like
all right man I was like he's like you
know don't worry about the dope you know
God I got you and I'm like but I got a
condition I'm like what Cog you gotta do
it by black dude like
yo I'ma tell you this
I go to my black barber but when I'm
going out with my wife when we're going
to somewhere special
I'm going toward Dominica a Dominican
I'm not gonna lie I'm not gonna lie I
gotta respect they they haircut games
son
that line the line that they put I don't
know how they do it I don't care and
it's it's the majority of the Dominican
Barbers that I went to
they Shape Up game is so lit it's crazy
so I don't know I'm gonna have to
probably take you to the Bronx and take
you to a Dominican ball with you here
the white people talk about like the
Bronx and you know queens and stuff man
I'm sorry I want to stay out of those
you know I come up there and you guys
let's go to Manhattan shirt but then
like I hear like certain things and I'm
like nah I think I think I'm fine
next time you come you staying with me
because you know that's what has to
happen you know
but yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
see look look we're killing your
brownies yes me too lineup is different
I'm telling you I mean it is it's not
racist it's just 100 the truth if you
want to look sharp that night you best
to go to a Dominican barber man don't
play around I mean it's just like one of
those things where it's like you know uh
uh you know especially people with color
like their hair tone is different so a
lot of them y'all I'm getting into
Barber because I want our people to look
nice and white people don't have that
like most white people lose their hair
like be realistic like you know talking
to a bald-headed dude and you got here
shut up
not really like but but we talking about
one white and one black dude you go to
Walmart count white people they're gonna
be way more white people Ballers than
black people like yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I don't know I guess we're not
eating the same things
no it's technically you you eat a lot
healthier than I do you only eat fish
and stuff man yeah
but anyway shout out to your glorious
bed so I think we're going to get some
PC stuff man today
and um
I told you I'm 98 right all the time
my man James Gunn came out
he had to spit the facts for those dudes
who wasn't on the train
James Gus said I'm going to deliver you
the road map to my vision of the DC
Universe
and he sat there and gave it out for
free
where all the gunny haters
where is the gun haters I haven't seen
nobody go on that Twitter line saying
shut up James gonna like he got rid of
Henry got no
James Gunn said we want
to merge animation
TV and movies with all the same actors
with all the same voices
merged into one universe that's
indistinguishable from this format to
that format to that format and that's
how the format should grow addict
Tyler
is that a recipe for success or is it a
recipe for Destruction
well go ahead and talk Tyler make sure
the people can hear you
can you guys hear me yes sir hello hey
how's everyone doing
fantastic
ah you know I think it's uh
looking at this list it's
it's pretty good there's a couple things
in there I don't even know for somebody
who reads uh DC Comics but Booster Gold
as a TV show uh
Superman Batman with the new Robin I
think it's a recipe for success as long
as they keep up with it it's about
finding the right actors
you know if they hire some people and
things don't work out and then they're
scrambling trying to figure out if they
have to change people or what are they
going to do that's where the issues come
in so
Lord Taylor
[Laughter]
all right so why he gets back I have no
clue what happened there okay tell us
tell us the changes man there's a
there's a lot of things going on James
Gunn um probably you know he watched The
Flash he and he told you the flash is
the jumping off point for everything
that's changing in the DC EU uh he also
told you that he's uh happy with Shazam
Shazam is a done film they pushed those
three films back that which were done to
slate them off into this year so it's
going to be Shazam and then you're going
to get uh
uh The Flash and then after Flash Blue
Beetle and then you'll get Aquaman
um
he's very high on Blue Beetle
he feels that Blue Beetle can be his
Peter Parker he feels that Blue Beetle
can be his Spider-Man
remember he says you know as a kid as a
teenager you know in this universe he's
going to position Blue Beetle and he
believes that he has the ability to Turn
Blue Beetle into a household name
because what he realized is that the DC
EU needs a Spider-Man type figure
right something that's relatable to the
children of the time and something that
is topical enough that can spread like
wildfire because uh children really
can't identify with Superman they damn
sure can't identify with Batman and
little girls can look up to Wonder Woman
but they really can't identify with
Wonder Woman until they're a little bit
older so what he's trying to do is he's
trying to get teenage level characters
and you know you're going to do that
because I heard his love for Damian
Wayne now I like what he said with
Batman where he's going to attack her
from the Brave and the Bold standpoint
because the brave in the boat was some
of my best comic books now the Brave and
the boat usually had Green Arrow and
Batman or green
um Lantern and Batman but the Brave and
the Bold usually was a team up Marvel
had Marvel two and one a Marvel team up
where the thing in Marvel 2-1 would team
up with every hero and um Marvel uh team
up with you know Spider-Man and somebody
usually so what he's trying to do is
he's trying to use that aspect of the
Brave and the Bold and that storyline
with Damon Wayne and uh Bruce Wayne and
going deeper into that character because
like he said he loves the way that that
Robin is he thinks that Robin is the
best Robin
now what I feel James Gunn's best
attributes is is take and obscure
characters that you know nothing about
and making you feel for him he has a
couple of passion projects that he's
looking at and one of his first projects
that he's bringing across
um what was the name of the first
project that he's bringing across the
animation
do you remember
because I can I can bring it up but
um the first animation that he's he's
doing it's uh lesser known characters
but what he wants to do with these
lesser known characters the same way he
did with the Guardians of the Galaxy is
make you care about characters that you
never knew about
and then the reverence that he has for
Supergirl he gave you a distinct vision
of how he sees Supergirl opposed to
Superman
she didn't grow up and land with the
Kent family and she wasn't taught these
morals and stuff like that what she did
was she saw a lot of her friends and
families die
and she has a jaded outlook on the world
now you're looking at a super being that
has super class power like Superman
and has a jaded outlook on life so she's
going to probably be a little bit
rougher around the edges not the soft
super girl that we've been seeing so I
think he's taking that aspect with it
and then you have the Booster Gold TV
series I like Booster Gold he explains
his backstory that you got a uh on the
screen guys I do have a a list of
everything that's going on all right so
we got Superman Legacy that's going to
be a film
um I don't know if Tyler's back or not
uh please go ahead and speak whenever
you uh when you can speak Tyler so
that's going to be a film we obviously
knew they were going to bring Superman
like you can't have Superman
well you have DC without Superman it's
just how it is right um of the authority
I have no clue what that group is none
whatsoever that's that's one passion
project
then we got Batman and the Brave and the
bowl when I'm in what I'm curious is no
Origins they're going straight to his
kid
well they don't need it no more
you know
um the world the DC world
like he said Shazam is here these these
characters are here
so he doesn't have to tell you the same
story that you know we don't have to see
Batman's uh family die over and over
again but what we didn't see is we
didn't see Damian Wayne's story
right so I think he's going to attack
the Brave and the Bold through Damian
Wayne's eyes
and and give you a version of Batman as
a father instead of the the complete
Dark Knight I give you a different
aspect of Bruce Wayne as he tries to uh
have this young assassin uh become a
little bit more civilized and and and
deal with Society because you know he's
Rich so he's a rich assassin you have to
change the mindset of the child because
the child has been formulated to be this
uh killing machine from a young age can
you guys hear me now yeah there you go
yeah so I think he's gonna take the same
approach they did with Spider-Man where
if we've seen the backstory already
they're not going to keep showing it
over and over we've seen Batman's
origins how many times so I don't think
there's any need to we've never seen
Damien uh I'm just I'm assuming same
with the Green Lanterns if they're gonna
have Hal Jordan and Jon Stewart in there
I'm assuming we're not going to get any
kind of uh origin story for that do you
think it's going to be a buddy cop film
it might be
I don't know what the fascination is
with making Green Lantern TV show I feel
like that's to me I feel like Green
Lantern's a movie like Booster Gold
definitely Tv show uh Amanda Waller
definitely TV show but I'm surprised
this is like the third time they've
talked about making Green Lantern to a
TV show do you think that that's WB
pushing to have content I will get push
back on that
I will give push back on that thought
because
um how he said it it's a crime Thriller
uh and they're police officers they're
detectives right and they said the the
precinct is
um Earth so
I mean if if you tell a like you can
tell episodes
and and it's this episode uh this
happened uh I think it's a different
take on a a High character but we also
got to remember
that as powerful as Green Lantern is
he's just a human
and he is tasked with uh taking over the
the what is it this this sector I forgot
the name of the sector but um that
Encompass Earth and then you know um you
know Jonathan Stewart takes over that
part where he becomes the the fairlax so
I don't know how he's going to attack
that because you can't have two Green
Lanterns occupying the same sector
right there can only be one so is it
going to be that uh Jon Stewart is a
rookie
and he's uh getting ready to become
detective in another galaxy and he's
going to go off that way or are they
going to do it as you know how that's
turning bad and he's a corrupt uh Green
Lantern you know how would they do the
story so I think they have something
crafted in place that you can do it
episodically as a TV show and and work
from there but it's cool real quick when
it comes to the lantern thing you know
I'm resulting to you too you're the
comic book people
I I do have all the colors of Green
Lanterns like on the screen
I I didn't know there was this many okay
I thought there was a yellow one
and a green one that's all I used to be
okay so it I I assume what I've been
told is I assume they go off of certain
uh certain emotions that you have yeah
so correct you have death anger Envy uh
greed greed righteousness uh holy
um jealousy
uh I forgot what the other ones but
um what you have to read is this story I
would tell you I was I'm gonna send you
a link to the whole storyline of the
darkest night
and that is Green Lantern's Greatest
Story great Comics greatest story ever
written just to clarify we're looking at
this all right right
they're going to be a lantern TV show
which I I would agree with you Tyler
five years ago but I feel like TV has
gotten to the point where it might not
rival a lot of movies but I think it's
in the same realm like you could tell in
a lot of cases you could tell a better
story than you can in in movies uh so
like to me when you look at all these
colors uh obviously and you know you
said there could only be one Green
Lantern uh in every sector now do all of
do these rings have a society or is it
like one and duns with some of them like
only one person got the black ring oh
like Power Rangers like no
Orange right unless they change the
orange only has one user as far as I
know
because that's all read yeah that's
greed all of these uh lanterns are
different groups they don't mess with
each other
all right they don't mess with each
other it's uh I'm trying to give you the
simplified version I can tell you the
complicated version which is no no we
don't got a show for that
um but the simplified version is they
all have their own groups they're by
themselves they don't mess with each
other and nine times out of ten they're
fighting each other
all right so all right so now with that
in the interception because they said
that that TV show is gonna be two
Landers is it two Green Lanterns yeah
two greens okay so and he said there's
gonna be other Green Lanterns
so do you think that they will
eventually try to sneak
a like a lanter from a different color
in this just to show Variety in the show
or do you think they'll show that for
maybe a movie that comes out after the
show
um
they said that the Green Lanterns lead
to overarching bigger story
I believe that's the darkest night
I believe
see Marvel's biggest story was The
Infinity Gauntlet
we already see crisis on infinite Earths
with the TV show
I don't think James Gunn wants to tell
that story if it's been told already
and no one's told the darkest night so I
believe that he's going to use the Green
Lantern TV show to build up a larger uh
base because remember he said every
actor that plays in whatever role it is
is going to be traversal throughout all
of the stuff throughout all forms of
their media which would be
um anime
TV and movies
so I think they're going to build up the
characters all the way straight to the
darkest night and they're going to
accommodate in that and that's going to
be his Infinity war and Infinity
Gauntlet because that story is that big
yeah that'd be nuts if they put that on
film
what question question to you guys this
Swamp Thing that's the only one that
they said that didn't seem like it
mattered it seemed like that was a
personal project for someone who was the
Swamp Thing
is the is it a DC you villain that
they're making a movie about like
you didn't see the Swamp Thing or the
when they had it right that was a
psychological Thriller too
[Music]
um
he's a tortured soul
that is trapped in the swamp thing's
body
and he is supposed to free
uh
he's like he
okay
him and man thing are the same man thing
is inside Marvel Swamp Thing is inside
DC
right
and then and if you saw a wolf by night
werewolf by night
the man thing and Swamp Thing is pretty
much the same I just feel that but
they're both intelligent I was just
gonna say I thought that the Swarm thing
was a little bit more intelligent than
man thing man thing's a little bit more
lumbering and swarm thing has a little
bit more Purpose with the people that he
uh goes and he he's like grouped but
lives in a swamp but he has different
kind of powers so but
he's a tortured soul
so would you guys assume that these
films these top five Superman the
authority Batman
uh Supergirl and Swamp Thing is like the
is well maybe not Swamp Thing I don't
know depending on how uh important I
don't know anything about him do you
think that's going to be like the
foundation that the future of DC film
stand on yeah absolutely they're trying
to hit every corner of the DC Universe
because the Swamp Thing he's more of the
like mystical
uh Constantine
uh the more mystical kind of people
where you have Batman with the detective
the human kind of aspect of the earth
Heroes Superman Green Lanterns uh it
feels like they're trying to hit like at
least one cornerstone of each part of uh
the DC Universe that they can build off
this one main character and go into
build into a bigger story darkest night
whatever the story may be and uh yeah so
I mean I I'm gonna be honest I don't
really know anything about Creature
Commandos or the authority
yeah so I kind of I couldn't tell you
where those fit but
so do do just that clarify do you guys
think that like it's good they're gonna
run you know what I really liked about
this that even Marvel won't do
there if if any of these characters
they're like look like we're gonna run
TV movies and games and they're all
going to be the same universe yep and
that's bold
because now if someone makes a an
animated thing you have to let make sure
that they can voice it on top of doing
anything they're doing currently like
you know you guys are right man James
Gunn might be the person man he might be
that guy I told you I'm right 98 of the
time and um I knew he was the guy we
wouldn't have got the piss poor uh phase
four if they were to let James Gunn do
what he was supposed to do but different
when one door closes another door opens
different opportunities and I'm just
excited that he's excited I'm excited
that he's he's sitting there with
Stewart and they're going over
everything and they're planning out an
eight to ten year plan for what's coming
next and he said HBO Max so I think he's
going to try to deliver enough content
to keep HBO Max still going I heard they
were supposed to be defunct and it was
supposed to be just under HBO and
umbrella but who's knows you know um
maybe we can stop hearing about people
screaming for the Snyder verse and the
Snyder uh situation and we can just dig
into what he has on the plate because
the real proven point is going to be the
Blue Beetle movie because that's going
to be his movie right uh that was not
his flash is not his Aquaman isn't his
but that Blue Beetle movie that's his
and we're going to judge him based on
that Blue Beetle movie
I think they're still filming so it
should probably be next year right is
that when that comes out yeah so I work
during the day so I only saw a brief
clip of him talking and that's what got
me excited is you watched James Gunn
talk about these and he looks excited
for this he has his fingers and
everything and I I already thought he
was going to be good but seeing him and
the one clip I saw talking about it
every single thing he put out there he
looks excited he looks ready he wants to
do this he he hand-picked each one of
these characters I think it's gonna be
good I think the
hardest part might be the casting part
because this is going to be a long haul
you sign one of these contracts you're
not doing anything else if you're doing
video games TV movies like it's going to
be a it's going to be a busier schedule
than Marvel has their people on right
now yeah because they they're they're
crossed they're pretty much and you know
if you think about a king and Tyler
that's a genius move because not only
are you uh captivating on a a TV aspect
and movie ass but you're also bringing
that over the animated thing and if you
look at it Marvel did the the TV thing
like like years into it
let me ask you a question okay voice
actors that don't do acting
are they going to be an uproar
yeah yeah
we we thought about it in the aspect of
continuity
now you're breaking the norm because
let's say you take Chris Evans and I
mean Marvel did it with uh Marvel
Zombies right or the what if
they had the voice actors that acted the
actual characters and they went back and
they uh voice acted the characters in
what if
but
you're talking about
taking
this one of those shows
taking those characters
and possibly Crossing them over to a TV
show would probably be inside the Green
Lanterns
and taking them and putting them on the
big screen now we don't get TV actors
crossing over to the big screen that's a
huge taboo we don't get voice actors
that can actually act their character on
the big screen and on terrestrial
television so what he is doing is he's
breaking down Norms but is he causing a
riff in the voice acting Community
because people that stake their lives on
well the voice of Batman right the
well now if you can't act on a TV and
act in the movies we can't use you
do you think that's going to encourage
people to to get better do you think
that would actually hurt them casting
because now they have to have a specific
type of person that's willing to do that
uh because if you think about it
especially if they're big on the games
where they want to build a a gaming
Universe with the actual DC Universe
right that means you got to get someone
that's willing to do mocap most likely
because they're going to want them to
look they're going to want them to look
similar so that means you guys you got
to during the interview thing it's like
have you ever voiced animation uh no
next have you ever acted in a movie no
next have you ever watched a video game
no next are you willing to though yeah
this is this is the thing you're gonna
have to have the the actor and we know
that we're gonna get great actors and
actresses
because they are going to be
knee-deep a hundred percent invested
into this character it's I think it is
going to matter too on how much the
funding is like right now it's gonna be
crazy going out the gate but if a couple
I'm concerned that in a couple movies
that they're not seeing a return that
they would expect supposed to be high
like I'm hoping James Gunn has humbled
them I'm like look your last stuff ain't
doing it you tried it for years you're
gonna have to you have to work with me
we're not gonna come out the gate
swinging fences but if you give me a few
years of doing this I can promise you a
semi-return like Marvel has but you
gotta stick with me you can't just cut
funding because this movie didn't do as
good as this movie like I'm concerned of
that I think that's the biggest concern
is WB just with their history and the
way that they love to stick their nose
into things
um I think that's probably my biggest
concern is what kind of leash does he
have and how much are they willing to
step back yes well we already saw how
much power he has he got rid of the rock
um we got 79 people we got 37 likes like
my man akw said hit that like button and
share it out to your friends cause the
main event is about to be yeah we're
talking we're about to talk about the
last of us uh so uh Kyle do you want to
stick around for the last of us thing
sure
is that okay with UK oh yeah I'm down
with that yeah so all right all right
I'm ending this all right did y'all see
The Last of Us and I'm gonna watch them
tell you guys I'm talking to the chat
right now
if you don't want this episode spoiled
for you
I suggest you turn around
close the door
and walk away yeah but we we we will be
over talking about our perspective of it
before we start like spoiling stuff it's
not going to be extra extra but we will
be talking about our overall perspective
of the show first so if you don't want
nothing interrupted head out the door
right now uh right now you good but here
in about five minutes you ain't good all
right so
King yes I'm gonna let you two go first
because
I think me and YouTube because I already
talked to Tyler a little briefly about
this
I think we're gonna differ on this one
oh I think not
um
Anybody Seen the Last of Us uh two
no James Gunn doesn't shy away from
I mean James gonna well I'm still stuck
on James gun
on Neil druckman doesn't shy away from
controversial things
at all
at all oh
Neil druckman
is a disrupter
he's chaos
stirred up in a hornet's nest and
released on your face
um
this episode
had me feeling uneasy
from the very beginning of the episode
to the credits going up
in the episode
and I and I know people are going to say
oh King is no no no no you don't know
why I was uneasy
starts off we already know that Tess is
dead
and uh Ellie is left
with Joel
then you you could tell that Joel is a
little bit perturbed
that he's stuck on this
situation with this kid that he doesn't
know that probably is going to turn into
a monster at any damn second
that he lost the only person that was
his person
that he was in charge to protect
and he has now this new thing
that he has to care for
and he goes to eat his food and he
throws his food Loki was guilt-tripped
into doing like it was it was yeah
but what Ellie did at the very beginning
of this show the very beginning she set
a tone for the rest of the show you
ain't blaming me right
damn right she damn right said that tone
right there
don't blame me for what went on
you took you had a choice you want to
get your battery or whatever the hell
that was like you know I said the balls
on this kid
but she was speaking facts
that that
part right there encapsulates
the episode
and their
meeting
of
yo tough dude but I ain't no pushover
type of kid
uh you you know you're dealing she's a
different breed
a kid
but she's a kid too so you have to look
at it every every every five seconds my
wife because I suck my teeth and my wife
is like
yo she's a kid she's never been outside
just thinking about the first time you
were sitting inside a car or you was
walking in a forest so you were doing
whatever she's going to do what little
kids stuff do
so okay that's my frustration with that
that the interaction
with Joe and Ellie
when she she does stuff that puts
herself a direct Danger
with joelen in the vicinity and he's not
knowing that he has to keep his eyes on
kids because he hasn't had a kid around
in such a long time
and he has to keep his eyes on this kid
at all times because this kid is always
into something every episode you leave
for every second of that episode you
leave her alone she's doing something
that she should not be doing and it's
bad parenting on Joe's part but Joe
doesn't want to be a parent anyway he's
like guilt trip to be a parent
and
it's it's just a nice Dynamic when he
tries to Shield her from what was up the
road
and her being a defiant kid brushes him
off like what you don't think I'm tough
enough to see it you know you don't
think I can see this you don't think
that uh I can handle this
and she gets a chance to see what he's
trying to Shield her from but that was
Joel trying to be a parent because I
guess he started softening his heart
started softening from all that crust
that built around it from his daughter
dying and him going through this world
rough
he was trying to Shield her from what
they were going to see
and I thought that was touching
but she's not like his kid that passed
she's a little bit rougher
she's a little bit
curse around the edges
and he has to learn this kid and I
thought that was a really good
interaction between the two I want to
know your thoughts on the action just
between Joel and Ellie and those brief
scenes because the episode really wasn't
about them
but that that that that that interaction
that they're getting to learn each other
without the barrier of tests being the
mom figure there just Joe
and Ellie
I'll let you go first Tyler
I love their Dynamic I played the game
big fan
I wasn't sure because he looked so much
like the character I was like man I
don't know how this girl's gonna work
because she doesn't look anything like
the character uh but they're Dynamic on
the show is great and I think they both
do a good job of
I've never been in a car this is great
what can I play with and him you can see
he's frustrated but he's also trying to
remind himself that
she's never experienced anything and I
don't know how to handle this I think
their Dynamics great
I think it's one of the best parts of
the show so far yeah I think it's good
too I I think for the most part their
chemistry is on point and I don't think
anyone can dispute that sure you can
just dispute maybe casting was was error
at this point I am used to her her as
Ellie like it's just it is what it is
where I could deal with it uh you know
but I I do think that that particular
part of the episode was perfectly fine
especially that moment where she comes
across uh it looked like a clicker like
a messed up clicker in the basement but
he wasn't a clicker he didn't turn all
the way yet oh okay half his head so I
didn't know if like the Collision like
knocked half of it off or something so
um yeah she wasn't making that clicking
noise any uh either so it just I thought
that was good I thought that was good uh
you know there's a lot of good moments
there and then we get to the bill part
all right now how did you how did you
guys feel about the bill part oh let me
ask you a question in the game isn't
Bill Black
no no he's white he's white okay because
I was confusing him with the other guy
remember they found the town the black
guy was like up in the one with his
brother yeah yeah that's after this all
right I think that's supposed to be the
next episode okay I just
I started all over again in the game
this move this show movie show
has me back at the game
shout out to Sony for doing a great job
because
do you think that they should have
released the the game after all Eight
Episodes debuted because I feel like a
lot of people are a little bit down on
the show in terms of we already know a
lot of the story because we literally
just played the game they literally just
re-released it again for us to play it
no I don't think so I just finished part
one on the PS5 I just beat it Sunday
before the show and I'm so happy I
played it because there's so many things
I forgot
and that's my that's my thing like yeah
I want to remember these things because
like I I just asked you I thought this I
totally forgot about this character
right
so he's a Doomsday prepper a survivalist
that he calls himself
and he was right
how many times
can we say this doomsday preppers or the
survivalists are right this guy
was right for everything that he did the
plans that he had in place because as
soon as the military came and took the
people away and started killing the
people because he didn't trust the
government at all all his conspiracy
theories were right
so he said
his plan was sound
and he went right into action fortifying
his little city his little town
for himself
but the one thing he didn't count on was
he was absolutely alone
that alone stuff works for but a little
bit of time
until you start missing
interactions with people we've seen
people go crazy all the time with that
alone stuff like Castaway like dude
literally befriended a ball like wasn't
nobody else showing up
so you know this I mean he had
everything
he had unlimited uh you know fuel he
wasn't driving around anyway he stayed
in this town he'd just go from point A
to point B so he had enough uh uh gassy
I think he drained what the two gas
stations that was in the town he drained
them and he had enough gas to go to
another town to get more gas or whatever
you know he had generators he had he had
a quick too like quick as soon as they
left he went right in because he knew he
has to get there before the looters
everything that he did was on time spot
on turn the gas on like after they
turned it off and you know what I like
the the resourcefulness a bill that he
he he was a dude of all traits he knew
exactly what to do he knew exactly how
to make his little traps he knew where
to go what to get he he knew it's it's
like you said he's been living his
entire life for this particular moment
the moment where he can shine yes but
straight to the boat to get as much
stuff as possible no other reason no no
I'm just gonna get as much things as I
possibly can
Depot and turned it into his his home
shopping center he was so he was a
renaissance man a resourceful man he
didn't forget to go to the liquor store
and get the finest wine
see that might have been missed by
people right he went in and got one case
of the best wines they had did not
liquor
wines
and I noticed that
I was like hmm
and and
the animals that he caught he dried them
out he cut he cut the finest Meats off
he knew how to cook I mean this man was
prepared
to do and The Time stuff
the military couldn't find him in the
house they didn't detect any sound waves
any anything
soon as they left him he was writing he
was right they found that hatch he was
ready
now he would have got far but he was
ready they would have to blow their
house up
now it was probably more of this thing
just leave that crazy dude there we're
leaving we gotta go
I took out five of us already nah so
I know everybody see me smiling
the uneasiness I told you guys that I
had from the beginning of this episode
until the end to the credits went up
the uneasiness of Joel and Ellie how
that Dynamic is gonna work how are they
going to come to a meeting of the minds
and then the uneasiness
a bill
how he's going to get this done I
automatically take myself and put myself
into his his shoes how would I do first
of all I'm dead all right run out of
food Memphis dead
I didn't fortify anything I didn't do
anything that he did whatever but
I'm like wow he's alone there
and then one day
a trap I think you should hit that
spoilers bro I think you should put
spoilers down at the bottom because this
is this is it this is it you gotta leave
now escape the building go out the back
door
leave now close the door or be spoiled
go away
this is the part where spoiler talk is
coming your way
so
this trap goes off and he hears a
hello
and he's looking down there
he sees the guy has a gun trained on him
you hurt
yeah just a little bit of a little
bruise
I'm uneasy with the dude because I don't
trust a damn soul in this movie in this
game in this world
we've been trained enough on this game
to know that everybody has an ulterior
motive we've all watched The Walking
Dead you don't trust humans you can
trust the zombies or the clickers more
than you can trust in humans because you
know exactly what their intentions are
and I'm like God this guy built this
whole little town for himself he built
this whole little world and none of this
stuff ever ends well man this doesn't
end well man
in
against
my own judgment not his he lets the guy
in the house to give him a meal
God takes the shower he gives him
clothes
and the guy is sitting downstairs but
he's looking at the dust
in the house he's like runs his fingers
across the The Mantel place and he sees
the Dust
but uh Bill cooks for Frank
and the meal is extraordinary
and then he brings uh I forgot the name
of the Y because it wasn't a Pinot duois
or
Merlot it was something else it was
something
that
only a trained pallet would know
and you know bill was like oh I'm not
supposed to know that he said of course
she would
because I guess Frank saw something in
bill that I didn't see him build that
you know he was a renaissance man but he
had a piano in the corner
and you know Frank gets on to the piano
and he fumbles through and he sings this
one but this is his favorite song that
he picks up
out of the the songbook
not knowing that that's Bill's favorite
song
any you know bills like not know
anything but that song and you know Bill
starts to sing the song but when Bill
closes his eyes my heart sinks right to
my stomach because I think that this guy
is gonna do something to build because I
already built an attachment to this
character
he survived all that stuff only to end
up in this position vulnerable with this
guy in a house and I'm like damn it man
not like this nail not like this
but then he's naked
and I was like that escalated very
quickly
that that went from zero to 60. like
that
um because you know they they got to a
kiss
and
yeah you're trying to figure out
is it real or is it fake I was saying it
the whole time is it real is it fake is
this a convenience lay
come on now how many times have you been
with a situation and ah she don't feel
like going home so she stays but she
knows if she stays
or the same thing with you I don't feel
like going home but I don't want to put
out but I got to put out if she wants me
to stay
so I'm thinking oh okay well there's no
food out there he has a long walk to
Boston
uh he's just doing whatever
no
it cost us six years later bro
I said six that's one hell of a
one-night stand six years later yeah so
I'm married already
yeah in the Old Government they married
what's that what's that law that that if
you're what's up common law you made
from common law man so okay look
we there's a couple things I didn't like
about okay
well you know people could sit there
they could say what they want
I didn't like the way they down created
Bill's character to me Bill was always a
very cautious man and there was a couple
things they did that made him so less of
a cautious man for instance
when uh when stuff popped off
Bill's shooting in the middle of the
road no cover just sitting out there
naked might as well be out there dancing
into that part yeah and I'm just sitting
here and I'm like that's not bill that
is not Bill Bill never the bill in the
in the game never would have got shot in
that in that scenario unless they
surrounded got a shot because Frank
touched him no he got shot because he
was in the middle he had no cover he
wasn't trying to take a cover he's
literally in the middle of the road just
shooting back to back not not trying to
cover no keep in mind that sure the
other people have no cover but if you're
in a strategic Advantage where you can
have cover for the other people can't
have cover bill would have chosen the
cover he wouldn't have just sat out in
the middle of the road just shooting
Willy like that
okay I'm gonna fight I'm gonna push back
on that
I'm gonna push back on that to say this
when everything popped off and Frank
woke up
bill was doing his job as a protector to
keep everything away from the house
right that's like if a large animal is
coming at you or whatever and you got
your kids behind you you're gonna make
yourself bigger than what you are
so he was making himself bigger by
standing in the middle of the road
if Frank was there he was behind him and
he was defending him he was in front of
him but he wasn't he didn't want Frank
to be there
that's why he didn't wake Frank up
but no it's not that it's the fact that
that isn't Bill's character
it is the character of the show I I get
that I get that here's my issue with the
King they were so close to magnifying
one for one the entire show so far in
those first two episodes and in this one
they they assassinated bill they might
as well have assassinated now people
could sit there and say oh you know uh
you're homophobic I had nothing to do
with that I didn't mind the episode I
thought it was a great episode until
certain instances I didn't like and I
didn't like the fact that bill
ultimately ended up doing a Romeo and
Juliet thing on himself at the end I
didn't like that
hold up hold up hold up no I'm putting
the whole junk on the table man that's
what's going on here I I was just
personally felt like
I think that they wanted to highlight
bill as being gay more than they wanted
to highlight him in the actual last of
his universe and that's how I personally
feel I personally feel if this episode
would have been fine King and Tyler if
there was an episode after it that he
didn't die and they did the stuff that
was in the game no he needed to die but
no here's my thing okay Bill was a he he
was a broken
broken man in the game but they don't
really go in a lot of detail of why he
was like that I thought this episode was
highlighting the years he had with Frank
and ultimately losing Frank is why he
was like that in the game well check it
out
all right I hear you jadedness and I'm
throwing it away
Frank was what
Bill needed
Frank was Frank was listen
bill was the protective bill
had all the Ingenuity all the know-how
Frank was all the subtle
when you looked at the house after Frank
got there for those six years there
wasn't no dust on the mantle place
and that that's not the issue though the
issue is you you got off your joint
when they had the argument
and Frank goes outside it was argument
because he wanted to paint
to decorate this to the neighborhood
see but that that is Bill's character
and I I don't mind that part that part
was I'm giving you why Frank was I mean
bill was in the middle of the street
imma give you I'm gonna give you the the
thought process
and first off I apologize we're gonna
like this we just had a lot of stuff to
talk about this don't worry this this is
about to be over soon
without Frank reaching out
we don't get tests we don't get Joe left
his bill would never have done it
facts
and Bill sat there with the gun out the
whole time didn't release his guard
didn't do anything because he is the
protector did you notice how Joe was
like Joe was sitting there and he's like
get that gun out of my face did you
notice that like yep you could tell Bill
wasn't scared of him but he respected
him at that moment he was like you know
what you right like he's he said that
much
he said let them do what they doing
because and they did that respectfully
after they went inside the house and he
showed the house off
because
listen you got to have balance Frank
brought balance to Bill
all right
him outside shooting in the middle of
the street he was protecting his block
he was protecting his house he was
protecting his mate he was protecting
his love because he didn't have purpose
before then remember
he was just surviving he was a
survivalist
so everything is popping off and he has
all the distractions going off they
don't know how many people's there but
they do see that crazy MF in the middle
of the road with this shotgun and the
rifle popping off
so either you're gonna get burnt up a
shot up but you won't get the hell up
out of here so when Frank comes behind
because you know Bill probably thought
he can clear this up before Frank even
wakes up
so when when Frank comes behind he looks
over to Frank like did you get hit or is
something wrong and he took his eyes off
the pride for one second and got wounded
I'm thinking bill is going to die
I'm thinking that's it yes he said I'm
getting cold but then the next scene
it's like 10 years later or something
like that yeah you know what I honestly
thought was gonna happen I don't know
about you guys I thought that
something was gonna happen and he would
there was going to be an incident where
where Frank's like are you okay and that
he was gonna get shot in the head or
something yeah and then and then it was
going to pan out and then you'll see Joe
coming to Bill's house and that's how
Frank died like people in the chat look
I get it Frank didn't like Bill in the
actual game I get that but it's like
look at the end of the day all that's in
relevant it doesn't matter I don't mind
them making them closer in the in the TV
show I just mind the the character
assassination and making Bill do stuff
that he would not have done in the game
and it would be different if they change
rassic stuff up until now but they've
been very one-to-one even scenes from
the game to the to the TV show say it's
word by word what was said in the game
that's my issue I'll hear you
uh and I'm Gonna Let You Go Tyler but I
just got to get my balls off because
Atticus attic is grinding my gifts
[Music]
um
when they switched off and he's in a
wheelchair we don't know what the hell
happened if Frank is looking I mean
Frank is looking worse for where
and uh Bill's looking a little bit
better and they're caring for each other
but it was a little thing
that I noticed
they were listening they were waiting
for
the song on the radio from them
remember in the first episode where he
was like they're waiting for something
to come across the radio did you hear
anything or whatever whatever chatter
and at the end of that episode you heard
the song playing
that was the same song that was playing
here
yeah so it was Bill that that was was
sent out the right well well Bill of
Frank
and and the song was a dangerous song it
was at that time right probably couldn't
move it probably was Bill so right
so it was a danger song If something
went wrong they would hear that song
play on the radio and they would know
that it's not safe to go there or
whatever right and I was like oh snap so
I mean I caught it and I felt very good
about myself that I'm paying attention
but um
you have a problem with the suicide I
don't
I don't
he had no more purpose
the person that you have is right there
you got to make a decision right there
right now in this decision right now I
don't know if you if if you're going to
believe in God in this moment or not I
don't know if you're gonna believe
because the world went to S uh that that
you have no hope but
at this moment that person that has been
your person
for over the last 16 years
they want you to help them check out
that's a hard pill to swallow
and then you're left with I'm gonna be
by myself
to do that again no
he did the only logical thing that you
could when this dystopian world I feel
you
but I'm still saying cat like so we have
the same conversation earlier and at
first I kind of agreed with him I was
like man I hate that ending because I
love the interaction between Bill and
Ellie in the game right it's great it's
awesome
uh I think the one thing that both attic
and I
didn't think about and I thought about
this after we talked was in the game
Frank left bill
so we're seeing bill
without his love there anymore so the
erratic I'm gonna protect it myself
isn't in a relationship he left him
so now in the show we're seeing how he
responds when he still has him it's a
whole different person you're gonna
react completely different when you're
by yourself and this person has left you
and you think they're probably already
dead at this point rather than when
they're still right beside you and okay
I have to protect them at all costs and
I didn't think about that until after
the fact too but in the game they're not
together anymore
uh so he's gonna act a lot different
than he does in the show when they're
growing old together and I think that
change makes the episode a lot better
than I initially thought because you
just that it's
changed
that was so close
him up
I I understand ultimately where you're
going with it because I believe me you
and me is like mine I thought this
episode
represented uh love in a dystopian world
and it and whatever love you find in
whatever form it takes
you hold on to it and you protect it
with all your heart and and and that's
what Bill did but Bill protected Franken
and Frank brought a little bit of flavor
a little bit of life a little bit of
living
in a dead world to Frank he brought the
strawberries he traded a little gun he
said one of the little ones
for them to have fresh strawberries
he wanted to get dressed up eat a great
meal and it was a very key part where he
told him
do you love me
well I want you to love me like I want
you to love me
and I was like wow
wow because he asked him for the
ultimate
the ultimate to to help
take somebody
a way that is actually your all
but they're in pain and he doesn't want
to do it anymore
he doesn't want to do
the broken stuff because if you looked
at it Frank was the healthy one Frank
was the one that was jogging getting
bill into shape
so to see him in his wheelchair
it was crushing his Spirit yeah he's not
able to get around and do the stuff that
he wants to do and to see that
diminished man at that point in time
Bill still love frank for who Frank was
and he didn't see him as a broken
individual
man that was a serious
serious episode
because I told you I felt uneasy from
the beginning of the episode until the
end and they kept it classy they didn't
show
the bodies
it showed an open window
they didn't think that was like a direct
towards like the window in the beginning
of the game too it's like I said like I
didn't mind this episode there was
things that happened in Bill's town that
I just wanted to see in the show like
the school we're not getting that
anymore uh Joe hanging upside down we're
not getting that anymore not getting the
dialogue between you know Joe Ellie and
Bill there's a lot of scenarios where
those were Stepping Stones did Bill's
story mean anything to the main story no
it did but I will say that that was a
stepping stone that got Ellie and Joe
trusting each other more was the events
that happened in that town and to me I
felt like they didn't care about none of
that
I think they're going to find a
different way to bridge those gaps
um
I thought this CC this episode
because remember I played that game
twice
I don't even remember the character that
much like that
but I won't ever forget this
and I think this is a way because
somebody put in the chat what they said
uh
somebody said okay hold on the geek the
geeky nerve this is the adaptation the
game is still there if you want that
this is the show they're raising the bar
in his opinion and
I believe that Neil went back and
thought about things that he wrote that
he put down
that he wanted to do over he wanted to
have done over
and I fail you but when people say
addict
they changed a part of the story that
didn't really mean much to the overall
the overall perspective of the story
and then I I pushed back saying well
what did this story mean to the overall
perspective of the story
you could go back and forth with that
argument like to me there was more that
happened in that town than just bill and
there was a lot of aspects that bill was
present for but it didn't revolve around
Bill and to me I would have wanted that
to be present on screen you know I
didn't mind this episode I would have
just have liked that bill didn't die at
the end in the next episode was about
the movements of finding the stuff for
the truck and you know going from the
point to point and I get it I get why
they did it they wanted to broaden that
story because that wasn't really talked
about in the game but we could go back
to the game as well where there's
there's a note from Frank pretty much
see he said he hated bill so it's like
you didn't just change something you
obliterated The Source material to make
to to force that that's how I feel okay
because if you go into that standpoint
it's like they there was there was
content there
they found Frank he hung himself in the
game because he took his battery he took
Bill's battery
and to me what we saw doesn't even
remotely resemble what actually happened
I don't I wouldn't want Frank to steal
his battery well it wasn't it wasn't
about stealing or not stealing they
threw that entirely out it's about
people say this is a different this is
an annotation
okay I get that but what we saw was
nowhere near what was in the game in any
way shape or form either it was
completely changed I'm good with it I
mean I walked away from this episode
all the way to the end
I was uneasy
and um I made like peace with the
episode because I really like Bill as a
character right I really like
the Ingenuity the renaissance man of
Bill the protective bill
that they get it done dude I really like
Bill
and then I really like Frank
because Frank was as genuine as he was
when he was in that ditch
you know and he he was there for Bill
and he put a shine to to Bill's world I
feel you I I just to me it's like I
thought they could have did both I
really do truly genuine felt that they
could have gave this scene in all its
Integrity but still give me the stuff
that happened in the town you know what
I'm saying let me ask you a question
okay did they show
did we get to know Frank in the game
no
but he was mentioned but it was never he
was never okay he never actually seen
him until until you found his dead body
let me let me ask you this again
did this give you a better context
of Bill and Frank's relationship
yeah it it did a good job and but see
that's not my issue right my issues
wanted to make sure that it plays the
game they could have back a door they
could have easily have done all of this
it's just I feel like if you want to go
and expand this that's going on you know
Bill and Frank's uh love life and Bill
and Frank's uh entire journey together
that's fine but I feel like
killing bill at the end is where I draw
the line because it's just like this
wasn't an important character over the
overall story of last of us but it was a
stepping stone that led to the events
that happened with The Last of Us
there's a lot of good dialogue that
happened to me if I would had my way
Frank would have pretty much like look
I don't I don't want you to do that I we
we still have people here that rely on
you you need to be there for them
and I would have liked him to have lived
I got to take my wife out my behind is
following right behind her
I feel you on that but that but to me
I would have loved it because it would
have shown why bill is angry like Bill
is you know what I'm gonna tell you this
I'm gonna tell you this
The Last of Us two was more Progressive
in a lot of its takes
and took a lot of heat
and maybe this scene was in Last of Us
won
but the times was too early before
to have those those scenes in that game
and I know the DLC came later
where Ellie came out
in the game because I never played those
DLCs and I'm afraid for that money
but um
during that period of time
I think Neil took out that part because
I think he wanted to tell this story
and I can't wait to get nail on load the
game I mean uh I ain't lost podcast
Sundays at 1pm uh Neil Mr druckman if
you watch me baby I definitely got a
bunch of questions for you
it's like I said man yo I don't think
that episode was bad I just feel like
I went into these first two episodes yo
they really sticking real close to the
source material man they're doing a
really good job and three and it's like
three like nil had like a string on the
piece of paper that says episode three
and he's just he's just linging it along
that's all I mean we've been going way
too long two hours we we we close in the
shop at this point is there anything
else you want to say concluding this
show episode no um we we went way over
budget
but we don't we don't normally go this
long it's just there was a lot that we
had the DC stuff
three movies
called you people we talked about uh you
know uh Violet night and
I did get a talk about our uh Ragnarok
um
uh man listen
it's this is a fun ride I'm having such
a great time
uh we have different stuff to watch
every week uh what what is it that you
want me to watch next week addict um
because I know it was something that I
wanted you to watch I gotta um you tell
me what
are you tell me what you wanted me to
watch
Netflix shows dropping this week I think
this
try to keep us up on the up and coming
stuff you know what I'm saying man you
know what I'm saying
uh so I think what's something that you
want me to watch I'm I'm texting my okay
I know it was something that I said I
wanted adding to watch and I'm trying to
get it right now yo when are we gonna
start doing the um the Post-it in the
the Whatchamacallit to get people to
vote on it I think we should do that
yeah but right now uh we will we're
about to announce the the patreon stuff
because that is up to date uh I actually
want us both to watch the first episode
of the new season of You by next Tuesday
you yes okay have you ever seen that
show episode okay then then yeah
you need to watch two episodes of you
that's all I ask
yeah first season
listen guys I'm gonna do a video drop on
Twitter to tell addict what I want him
to watch because I know I have it I just
forgot it and I was too caught up in
these episodes but we didn't give the
episode rating brother you about to walk
out the door without giving the other
episode I give this episode rate it up
five popcorn I give it a three
uh
yeah I I personally uh
feel like that you don't love you don't
you don't like the love it's with Frank
and Bill Bill killing each other at the
end well Frank killing I mean Bill
killing both of them but yeah
to me I just I just wanted them I don't
mind them deviating changing certain
things of the story but my biggest thing
when they make these is don't
assassinate character development and to
me you have the the pieces on there
built around that but don't assassinate
the character of the actual game
character and to me they they didn't
assassinate bill
I feel like Bill's character was intact
at that point right and I'm okay with
that but I was upset the fact that they
killed him so we didn't see that rough
uh that rough bill after everything
happened that upset bill that that
isolated bill that that you don't touch
that bill that's what I'm upset with
that that's what I'm personally have
said well let's play the game and I got
to see Bill again but I like this bill
yeah so okay uh we we do have a patreon
uh we've had a patreon uh first off you
know shout out to everyone that showed
up there we almost 100 people you know
I'm trying to do a better job at uh
sharing uh that we do have a a YouTube
channel it's right there go to that
click it subscribe it's pretty much
what's happening is it's going to be the
individual parts of it because I record
them separately and I'm throwing them
all over there their own thumbnails so
definitely go over there sub to that uh
we have a patreon uh we've been told
multiple times they want to see stuff us
react to certain things so we were
putting uh we're putting it on the
patreon because we do want to give value
to you guys over there on the patreon go
take a shower Frank you stink yeah
yeah so we we're going to do that and um
so how we've done it is we put it behind
the seven and ten dollar tier seven
dollar tier you get to watch all of all
the reactions that we do well monthly
hopefully we'll try to get a couple out
uh a week just depending on what's going
on King's watching Attack on Titan I'm
gonna find a good format that we could
do it on I think I'm probably about to
start watching Titans
uh the the HBO show yeah so I'll put
that on there and then what we'll we'll
do is uh we have a ten dollar tier you
do a ten dollar tier and what will
happen is you'll be able to to give us
suggestions and me and King will come
together and put a poll out on uh on on
Twitter or maybe patreon member and
we'll let you guys vote on that so that
that's over there I I don't know if you
guys can see this
dip down anime and uh go like follow And
subscribe my guys is out here man they
moving these streets
yeah so there's the uh there's the
patreon uh so go to there you know sub
yeah help some people out man uh we'll
be posting that dragons what's up we'll
be posting that here soon I think you
guys will really like the content we're
going to provide there obviously you
know we we we're gonna start doing like
q and A's too so for five dollars a
month on the patreon what you could do
is you can ask questions to IOP to the
attic show to r r and you can ask uh
stuff to combat talk so you know have a
little good uh back and forth with
everything uh we do have a 50 tier where
you could come on the show as a guest uh
we have expanded that now where you know
when you're in that 50 tier you can
choose to go on any of the shows but
combat talk because yeah
so that's what's gonna happen uh when I
start watching Titans I'll put that on
there I'll talk to King find out exactly
we're gonna do I do have a format I want
to do I have to go run it by King I'll
have to set out to help him set up on
his stuff and hopefully next week will
start popping out content on that but I
think you guys gonna enjoy it man I
think we're gonna we're gonna provide
some really fun stuff over there on
patreon but we put it in the thing you
know if you guys want to go there throw
a couple bucks a month man get some good
content because you know for for ten
dollars a month you get access to asking
us questions you can watch our reactions
and you can suggest reactions and
there's four shows weekly that you can
pop in there to ask questions with I
think that's a good value what are you
thinking I think it's fantastic that
fifty dollar till you can get on the
iron Lords podcast if you want to do
that that sound dope yeah but the thing
about the tier though uh the the 50 tier
is obviously we'll come together find
good days but you can ask to be on a
different show every month so you know
you feel like you're getting more you
know something pops off with the the
Marvel with DC
and I uh going we're joining Friday this
or tomorrow uh we got to join
um Whatchamacallit this uh this week uh
the movie thing uh because we have to
every week
we're going to have to go out and watch
movies and uh bring you that content
because it was a movie that dropped and
that's what it was it was a movie in a
movie theater that we supposed to see
and it just came out man Dungeons and
Dragons
Dungeons and Dragons
write that nail on the head that's right
yeah so we'll talk to you guys later man
we appreciate it you know man two hours
two hour r r we ain't never done that I
feel like it
it's because it's because we talked
about DC for a minute but you know me
just stating what we talked about go
make the show longer I appreciate you
guys coming back definitely showing at
the attic show tomorrow with me and dirt
you know I might bring on someone else
uh we're gonna have some pretty good uh
time tomorrow uh but I appreciate you
ever come through here and until next
time peace
hello
hold up actually right before I I quit
uh we're still live I want to try to
send you guys over somewhere man like I
feel like there's plenty of people in
this community that that could really
use the support go over there tell them
what's up uh so we're gonna see who who
can we send them to King
I don't know
uh we have Jamaican gamer he he's a
streamer that's pretty much all that's
being told uh so we're gonna send you
over there man he's a streamer you're
making games yeah he plays Call of Duty
a lot I think you guys are like go over
there tell them iron Lords podcast sent
you That's essential